[Music]
right welcome to the great stunning
smoky mountains um i've had the most
amazing week here and i've foraged for
the most amazing mushrooms and the most
incredible crawfish so i'm gonna make
you a crawfish omelet but done with a
twist because we have some of the local
cheese but not just any cheese
our director neil's cheese and so this
is a big one for me because um it is a
yellow branch
cheddar and this thing's done with the
most amazing basil running through it so
it's fragrant it's creamy and it's
almost like a prized cheese locally so
yellow branch beautiful cheddar with a
hint of basil running through the middle
now correct you because it's
farm stand it's not really chatter but
right i'm gonna go no no i'll take that
farmstead it's farm secrets
so raw cow milk farmstead and
it's flavored with basil that is correct
and dried tomatoes the dried tomatoes so
tongue tomato basil you know go like a
hand in glove and i love it because it's
got that nice creaminess but it gives
that richness to the omelette first off
get your shallots you want to caramelize
them slowly and a little bit of butter
and then lightly toss in
my beautiful crawfish
okay a little touch of garlic
slice nice and thin
and then from there
literally
season that with a little touch of chili
in there okay
now the scallions get them ready because
that's going to go in the middle
with the cheese
and we just literally
slice
all the way down get everything ready
we're making an omelette really
important to get all your ingredients
ready
and that then
gives you the essence to make sure those
eggs aren't overcooked
so
crawfish cheese shallots garlic
and look how can i not just
get some of these local mushrooms
and literally
slice that
now
get that into a little bowl
in
over to the pan
a little touch
of oil
small dab of oil
shallots
garlic mushrooms in and just
get them caramelized nice and slowly
roll in with a touch of butter
let's get them really nice and soft
touch of chili in there a little bit of
heat we don't do boring omelettes just
nicely done
now eggs
again
into a bowl flat surface in
the secret here is to get four beautiful
eggs
open
don't over whisk them just break them up
nice and lightly don't season the eggs
yet
it'll turn them gray season as it hits
the pan
okay now follow me crawfish
they go in
to the shallots
beautiful
now they've been blanched for 30 seconds
taking out their shells
and then just a nice little gentle saute
on there beautiful right eggs gonna go
in a touch of salt now
a touch of pepper
and one nice knob of butter in we go
so
let's do this together butter in that
gives colour to your eggs
melt the butter
now with your eggs
in
as a problem when you're cooking on the
mountain top everything slides down the
grill eggs in
now this is where we've got to move
quickly
okay
crawfish are beautifully sauteing nicely
now we go in
and we open up the eggs
and we cook them nicely
flatten it down
open up we want it nice and creamy in
the middle i'm gonna make it even more
creamier
so look
this is where that beautiful cheese
comes in
and look
great
that beautiful
cheese over
okay generously
get your crawfish
and lay that over
look at the colors popping
look at that
from there take your scallions
and then just line that cheese is
starting to melt beautifully
so i got that nice richness now just
tap it
super careful here now
you lift that up
you fold that over
you roll it roll it roll it roll it roll
it
tuck that in there
beautifully done
and then
out
and this stuff is too good
to waste
look at that
and that
is what i call
a beautiful
great
smoky mountain
cheese
crawfish
omelet
to [ __ ] die for
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch on catch up
on disney plus
[Music]